yeah uh Charlie cocked his back as
Daredevil uh did not goes back as
Kingpin
I worked with donofrio amazing guy any
chance you'll be back as Jessica Jones I
have no idea I hope so you really don't
have no idea no idea I hope so I hope so
I think that people love people love
Jessica I know because I live it and so
do you think there's a good chance I I
honestly I don't know and like Marvel
doesn't if they're so secretive I don't
know
um I'm just putting it out there that of
course I would be there in a second I
got I had to have my boots and jacket on
ready to rock speaking of that you you
kind of did you create the look yes and
I ruined it for myself because it
created a whole look for people I know
and I'm like [__] I can't wear my
regular clothes anymore the leather
jacket look yeah yeah I loved that yeah
she looked so [__] cool yeah I think
you have a lot to do with almost every
time I think the actor should yes but
you like even for Night books oh yeah
with our lovely Autumn who I just adore
and so hugely talented but like you
worked very close with her to get that
look of what you both wanted yes
envisioned it is very I am very very
collaborative and very Hands-On with the
costume designer always because
you know I sort of always start my
characters at home with like a
physicality or a walk and then like it's
the clothes it's the hey all of that
creates the character it's not like here
now you're gonna wear this now it's like
a real creation from the ground up and I
breathe all that life into it and I need
that and so yeah the costume on Jessica
Jones for sure like I spent
[__] little all of it